in real life advice but then I love this
up there we talk okay I'm gonna do
hip-hop if I do hip-hop media I'm gonna
say um it's up there podcast
they might even say all the smoke see
what I'm saying nah you didn't that's
what I'm saying
so you got to go all the smoke ah no
smoking hip-hop though right but that's
in the pivot the one with that
yeah but the athletes are having
somebody
at least they're having some of the best
podcasts like from Matt Barnes and
Stephen Jackson Brandon Marshalls
Pac-Man and Brian and Fred and Channing
yes um hip-hop media space I'm gonna say
the best podcasts are
drink Champs it's up there podcast
um
damn
I'm trying to think of people that I
know are audio yeah I'm trying to stay
away from the yeah yeah
more video than anything yeah
I that's that's yeah that's what I got
yeah honestly drink Champs and
it's up there podcast no I'm missing
I don't know
I don't I don't I don't know I mean
unless you count I said million dollars
worth a game already I guess yeah
you think about million dollars over
again that's so ill it's the same thing
with all of us yeah we are hip-hop but
we're not we're moving outside today
yeah we we men yeah we talk about real
issues like man you can go watch wallow
to try to save all these young Brothers
lives you know what I'm saying like
think about the stuff he told Thug stuff
he told poochy stuff he told King Von to
me that's bigger than yes hip-hop that's
a real OG
that's game I ain't hating on you yeah
and they showing that yo there's no age
limit to this yes you know what I'm
saying they're showing you that there's
no age yeah the spring chickens yeah no
and they Donald did 20 years they're not
trying to act no they saying enough they
tell putting that wrong game they ain't
trying to run from that you know what
I'm saying so I respect Walo and Gilly a
lot I think like you said they weren't
they weren't a lot of the market share
and they they doing a great job bootleg
Kev Kev is cool I got Kevin my top I
like hip-hop uh podcast